I've had two friends do lie detector
dress that debrief me on it yeah and
one of them was a super kind of honest
guy
and he
got got crushed by the lie detector test
it just as soon as it's as soon as they
because they make you lie to it so you
can see what it does yeah and as soon as
they even started to get to the thing
that he was supposed to lie about it
went off the rails huh
what so what it said he was lying when
he wasn't they say they say Hey Okay
Echo think of a number between one and
five
you got it in your head okay now when I
ask you if that's the number
say no and I go what were you thinking
of one and you go no what are you
thinking of two and you say no do we
thinking of three and if you were
thinking of three all of a sudden that
thing starts going off the rails so
that's how they set you up